hey what's up guys it's Pedro here from
new quarter calm and in this video we're
gonna give an overview of the crud
application that we're gonna be building
as well as going over what things you
should be familiar with in order to
follow along with this tutorial series
so the technologies that you should be
somewhat familiar with are nodejs and
expressjs which we're going to be using
for our server-side we're going to be
using a database called MongoDB and for
our client-side we're going to be using
jQuery the fetch API and bootstrap and
you should know a little bit about HTML
and last but not least for our
server-side and client-side we're going
to be using a programming language
called JavaScript so now let's actually
take a look at the application that
we're going to be building with in this
tutorial series so this is going to be
our to do application that we're going
to be building it's a very simple
interface so we just have a user input
box where we're going to type or to do
so let's say I want to type clean garage
I can do so hit create and you can see
that this gets stored now if I hit
refresh you can see that the data
persist so that means that we are saving
it within our database if I want to edit
this or something let's say clean room
instead I could click Edit and you can
see that we get updated with clean room
hit refresh data persists and if I hit
delete it deletes the to do and if I
want to create multiple to do is I could
say clean room clean house and etc and
all this data will persist within our
MongoDB database welcome to part 1 of
building our crud application from
scratch so essentially what we're gonna
do in this tutorial is install our
packages set up our Express application
and connect to our MongoDB database so
to get started I'm just going to
file I'm gonna go to open folder I'm
gonna right-click go to new we're gonna
create a new folder so I'm just gonna
call it
MongoDB underscore crud let's select it
and afterwards what I want to do now is
let's open up the terminal and from here
I'm just gonna type cos to clear the
terminal and that's because there's a
visual bug with Visual Studio code at
the moment and what I want to do now is
install our packages that our
application is going to be dependent on
so I'm going to type NPM in it and we're
going to pass in the flag wife to get
the default values and now I want to
install the body parson module and the
body parson module is going to be used
the parse JSON between the client side
and the server side next we're going to
install Express and we're just going to
use Express for routing next we're going
to install MongoDB and this is just
gonna be the MongoDB drivers and this is
gonna help us connect to our database
and last but not least we're gonna
install the path module and we're gonna
be using the path module just to serve a
static HTML file to the user so now that
we have our packages installed I'm just
gonna go up here I'm gonna hit ctrl B to
bring up the Explorer I'm gonna go to
package JSON I'm just gonna change the
main to app budget yes and this is just
a personal preference I prefer app
digest as opposed to index dot JSP this
we're gonna create two files I'm gonna
create my app by J's file and our second
file that we're gonna create is gonna be
called BBJ yes and this is where we're
gonna actually connect to MongoDB now
from here I want to code our app dot J's
file first so I'm just gonna click here
control B get rid of that Explorer and
we could get rid of the terminal for now
and what I want to do is start importing
our modules that we just installed so
I'm just going to say cons Express it's
equal to
prior Express and let's give a space
here and next what we're going to do is
bring in our body parts and module
afterwards let's create an instance of
our Express application so I'm just
going to say Const a p-- is equal to it
Express and let's call it now we're
going to tell our Express application to
use the body parson module and we're
going to be parsing JSON data sent from
the client side to the server side using
the body parts module next let's require
our path module after that let's bring
in our database stuff so I'm just going
to say cons VD is equal to require DB
and last but not least we're going to
have one more variable here and we're
going to call it collection and we're
going to call it a collection to do so
we're going to have a database and that
database is going to have a collection
within it called to do and that's going
to hold our R to dues so now let's head
over to our dbj s file and now we're
just going to import our MongoDB driver
so I'm just going to say cons [ __ ]
client is going to be equal to require
MongoDB and we're going to require the
[ __ ] client from it we're also going to
require the object ID from the MongoDB
module so I'm just going to say cons
object ID it's going to be equal to
require MongoDB dot object ID next let's
give our database a name so I'm just
going to say cons DB name is going to be
equal to and I'm just gonna call it crud
MongoDB after that we're gonna code our
URL and this is basically the default
location of where your MongoDB would be
located on your local machine so I'm
just going to type MongoDB localhost
27 0 17 and the last configuration that
we're going to give our database is the
options that we could pass in so I'm
just gonna say [ __ ] options and we're
going to be using the new URL parser
let's set that to true so now let's
actually give this a state so we're
going to be using this D bjs file to
actually create the connection between
nodejs and our MongoDB server so now I'm
just going to say Kant's state and the
default state of this is going to be
equal to null so this is going to
signify that hey we don't have a
database yet
next let's actually write our connect
method so I'm just going to say cons
connect it's going to be equal and we're
going to pass in a callback and we're
just going to say the following if state
dot DB so if there is a database
connection we're just going to call it a
callback if there isn't a database
connection we're going to use the [ __ ]
client to connect to the database
and here we're going to
if there's any errors if there's an
error we're gonna pass it back to our
callback if there's no error we're gonna
set the state and then we're gonna call
our callback alright so this is our
connect method let's not forget to add
the semicolon here and we got two more
functions to code so let's get to it so
the next function that we're gonna code
is to get the primary key so I'm just
gonna say cons get primary key and
they're gonna pass in the ID of the
document and all we're gonna do is
return object ID and we're gonna pass in
the ID that they passed in to us and
this is going to return an object ID
object which will be used to actually
query the database by the primary key
next let's actually create a method to
actually get the database so we're just
gonna say get DB and I'm just going to
say return state dot DB so now let's
actually expose all these functions that
we create it so I'm just gonna say
module that exports and I'm just gonna
say get DB connect and get primary key
method
alright so now I'm just going to save
this and now let's head back to our app
dot JS file so now that we have all this
set up let's actually connect to our
database so now I'm just going to say DB
connect and this is the function that we
just created in our DB file we're going
to pass in a callback and we're going to
say if error we're going to console dot
log unable to connect to database and
we're going to terminate the application
probably wrapped this within curly
braces and if we were able to connect to
the database successfully we're gonna
say else app that listen and you could
use whatever port that you want I'm just
going to use port 3000 and we're going
to pass in a callback and we're just
gonna say connect it say database app
listening on port 3000 so now if I was
to save this let's put a semicolon here
and then save it
let's go open up a terminal type CLS
again and a type node app and you can
see that we got no error so that means
we bypass this error statement and we
executed our else statement so we're
connected to database and our app is
listening on port 3000 welcome to part 2
of building our crud application from
scratch so in this tutorial we're going
to be covering our server-side
reapportion of our crud application so
we're gonna code to get routes the first
get route is actually going to send a
static HTML file to the user and the
second get route is actually going to
query the database for order to Do's if
an hour to do collection and it's going
to return that to the user
so let's actually get started encoding
this so I'm just going to go down here
I'm going to say apt-get and we're going
to give it a path of forward slash give
it this function and then when we get
down here all we're gonna do is send a
static HTML file so I'm just gonna say
res dot send file and here's where our
path module comes in handy join
now this file doesn't exactly exist yet
but we're going to be creating this
within a future tutorial so now let's
actually head on over to our second app
and I'm just gonna call this app that
yet and I'm gonna call this get to dues
then here we're gonna pass in our
function our request object our response
object and within here I'm gonna say DB
get DB now remember get DB is gonna
return to us our database connection so
now I'm just gonna say dot collection
and we're gonna pass in the name of our
collection and I'm going to call the
method find and we want all the
documents within our to-do collection
but this is going to return to us a
cursor and we don't want the cursor we
want the actual document so I'm gonna
call I met they called dot to array and
then within here and this is going to
take a callback function I'm just gonna
say error documents and let's actually
move this over a little bit and then
within here we're just gonna say if
there's an error we're just gonna
console this out to the user but
traditionally we want to send an error
message back to the user but if there is
no error what we're gonna do is first
we're gonna print this out onto the
console just to make sure that we're
getting our documents back from the
server and we're gonna say res dot JSON
the documents alright so now let's
actually test this out so I'm just gonna
hit ctrl has to save let's bring up the
terminal or a new terminal I'm gonna
type cos node app let's bring up Google
Chrome and then type local host for
3,000 and we called it get to Do's
and you can see that we get back an
empty array and that's because we don't
have anything within our database so
let's head back to visual studio code
I'm gonna hit ctrl C cancel out of that
let's start off the [ __ ] shell and now
I'm just gonna go back up here control B
let's find out what we named our
database so we named it crud
MongoDB so I'm just gonna say use crud
MongoDB I'm gonna say DB dot and let's
go back to app that yes
and see what we named our collection to
do I'm just gonna say to do dot insert
and we're gonna insert a couple of to do
so I'm just gonna say to do and I'm
gonna say clean room so let's insert
that and let's insert clean I don't know
garage so let's insert that all right so
let's cancel out of that note app let's
wait for our Express application to boot
up head over to Chrome hit refresh and
you can see that r2 dues are being sent
to the client side and that it is in
JSON welcome to part three of building
our crud application from scratch so in
this tutorial we're going to be covering
our server-side update portion of our
crud application so to get started let's
actually covert our route so I'm just
gonna say app top clip and I'm gonna
pass in borage / : ID now this is going
to be our route pram and ID is gonna be
the primary key of the document that we
wish to update next we're gonna pass in
our function so I'm just gonna say
request and response now from here let's
actually get the ID so I'm just gonna
say cons to do ID is equal to request
dot params by ID next what I want to do
is actually get the user's input and
that's gonna be found in the request
that body the user is gonna be sending
us JSON so I'm just gonna say Kant's
user input is equal to request that body
now from here let's actually connect to
our database so I'm just gonna say DVD
get DB then we're going to call our
collection which is our to do collection
now from here I'm going to call a
function called find one and update and
the first argument is going to be the
query object so what do we want to find
by so we're going to find by the ID so
I'm just gonna pass in ID and I'm just
going to pass in to do next what we want
to do is pass in the document that we
want to update with so I'm just gonna
say set and I'm gonna say to do : user
input dot to do next what I want to do
is pass in an option and the option that
I want is I want the return original to
be set to false so I'm just gonna say
return original and we're going to set
that to false let me just move this here
now from here we're gonna pass in our
callback function so I'm just going to
say error and we're gonna get the result
so now let's scroll down here and from
here we could test if there was any
errors and I'm just gonna print it out
onto the console but traditionally you
will want to send something back to the
user to let the user know that hey when
we try to update the document that you
want it we couldn't fulfill that request
so now I'm just gonna say else so if
everything went well we're gonna be
sending that data back to the user in
JSON format so I'm just gonna say result
so now let's add a semicolon here and
let's just double check this and all of
this looks good so let's actually test
this out so I'm going to open up the
terminal and clear a terminal node app
let's start up our application
we're gonna go to postman and you can
see here that I already have this set up
so the URL is localhost port 3000 this
is the ID of one of the documents that I
have currently we're making a put
request we're sending back JSON data
here so you can see here and this is the
data that we're sending back and we can
make this whatever we want so let's just
change this to clean something for
tutorial right so this is going to be
our to do and I'm gonna go here and make
a request so I'm just gonna hit send and
you can see that we get an error and
right away I already know what's going
on so when we pass then our to do and
this is a string we want an object ID
object so I'm gonna call DB dot get
primary key we're gonna pass in the ID
of this to do I'm gonna save this let's
actually cancel this node app rerun our
application we're gonna go to postman
again and this time let's actually go
over the response we got so it's
the number that we found was equal to
zero and that's because we didn't pass
the right ID for the primary key so now
if I send this this number should be 1
and updated existing should be equal to
true so let's send it and you can see
right here the number that we've updated
is 1 this document did indeed exist
within our database so it's true and you
can see the values that we have the ID
is still the same but we've updated it
to clean something for our tutorial and
if we hit another thing let's actually
make sure that this update is working
and we're going to say change to
something else I'm going to hit send one
more time and you can see the ID is the
exact same thing but we've changed the
to do to change to something else
welcome to part 4 of building our credit
application from scratch so in this
tutorial we're going to be covering our
server-side create portion of our crud
application so to get started we're just
going to code our route so I'm just
gonna say app that post so we're going
to be posting to do that we want to
insert within our database so we're
going to give it the path of forward
slash and then we're just going to pass
in our function the request object and
the response object now from here what I
want to end up doing is getting the
users input the to do that the user
wants to insert inside the database so
i'm just gonna say cons user input and
we're just going to say request that
body so the client side the user is
going to post json to us and that's
going to be within the request stop body
next let's actually get the database
connection so I'm just gonna say DB get
DB then from here I'm just gonna say
collection pass in our to-do collection
then I'm going to call a function insert
one the first argument is going to be
the document that we want to insert so
I'm just gonna say user input and the
second argument is going to be the
callback function so I'm just going to
say error and I'm going to say
result now from here we're gonna test if
there's any errors so I'm just gonna log
it on to the console now in a production
environment you would want to say
something more than just logging it onto
the console you'll probably want to
display an error message to the user
next I'm just gonna say else we're just
gonna send it back to the user I'm just
gonna pass it as JSON I'm gonna say
result result and I'm gonna say document
result dot ops index 0 now we're
actually going to test this out so you
actually see what's inside result and
what's inside result ops so now I'm just
gonna save this let's open up the
terminal new terminal just gonna clear
it I'm gonna say node app a startup
server let's head over to postman and
you can see that we have our localhost
port 3000 here with the /url we're
making a post request and this is a JSON
object that we're sending back to the
server so let's say that we want to post
clean something so this is a to do that
we want to insert within our to-do
collection so now I'm just gonna hit
Send and now you can see the response
that we're getting back from the server
so this is the result that we sent back
and this is the document so result has a
property of n so that's the number
inserted and it says that it was ok so
it was set to 1 so that means everything
was inserted properly and number two is
the document that we just inserted so
you can see the to do here matches up
here and it's given n primary key which
is listed here so now let's actually see
if this was saved so I'm gonna go back
here let's make a get request remember
what was our route we said
get to dues I'm going to go to send and
you can see right here that our to do
clean something was inserted inside the
database properly welcome to part five
of building our credit application from
scratch so in this tutorial we're going
to be covering our server-side delete
portion of our crud application so to
get started let's actually code our
route so I'm just gonna say app dot
delete and the path that we're going to
use is an Express / am so I'm just gonna
say forward slash colon ID and this ID
is gonna be died be the primary key of
the to-do document that we want to
delete from our database next we're
gonna pass in our function our request
object our response object now within
here the first thing we need to do is
get the ID so I'm just gonna say cons to
do ID is equal to request dot params by
ID next let's actually connect to our
database so I'm just going to come down
here and I say DB get DB then I'm gonna
call it a collection method I'm gonna
pass in our collection or to do
collection then I'm going to call the
function find one and delete so the
first argument is the query object so we
want to find this document by the ID so
I'm just gonna say ID then I'm going to
say DB get primary key and we're going
to pass in our to-do ID the second
argument is going to be the callback
function so we're gonna get an error or
we're gonna get the result so let me
just fix this by adding the curly braces
here
error or result let's see what's
happening here and this looks good so we
have our error and result next we need
to test to see whether or not there was
an error so if there was an error that
means we couldn't delete any so
if there was an error what we want to do
is actually print this out into the
console you can also send some kind of
warning back to the user that an error
has occurred otherwise what we're gonna
do is send JSON data back to the user so
now I'm just gonna save this I'm gonna
go to terminal
new terminal let's clear this out node
app and our application is running if I
go to postmen you can see that I already
have this running so we have our get to
do these route here so I'm just going to
send this again so you guys see that
these are all the to do is within our
MongoDB database so what I need is let's
say I want to delete this to do
inserting into the database so I'm just
gonna copy this primary key we're gonna
go back up here let's paste it so we
have localhost port 3000 and the ID of
the document that we want to delete I'm
gonna go here we're gonna make a delete
request and now if I hit Send let's see
what we get back and this is the
response that we're getting back from
the server so number deleted is 1 and
you can see the value of the document
that we deleted and we get ok with the
value of 1 so everything went fine
so let's actually prove this out if I go
back here get our - duze one more time
hit send you can see that the document
that was there is no longer there so
this is pretty much the server side
delete portion of our crud application
welcome to part 6 of building our crud
application from scratch
so in this tutorial we're gonna be
building our static HTML file that we're
going to be serving to our user so in
the previous tutorials we've created to
get route 1 of them is to serve the
static HTML file to the user and the
second get route is to actually get auto
to do is within our database so we're
gonna be focusing on this route so to
get started and
gonna hit ctrl B to bring up the
Explorer I'm gonna right-click new file
and we're gonna create a new file called
index.html well now I'm just gonna hit
ctrl B again get rid of that and now I
just want to head over to get bootstrap
comm so we're gonna be using bootstrap
for in order to build our HTML file so
from here you can see that bootstrap
actually gives us a starter template and
this is going to include all the CSS
that we need and the JavaScript that we
need so I'm just gonna copy this let's
head back over to Visual Studio code and
now I'm just gonna paste this in here
let's actually change the title so I'm
just gonna change it to do read
application and we're going to get rid
of our h1 tag here so from here let's
give it a container
the first row is going to be where we
input our to do user input the second
row is going to be an unordered list
which is going to be displaying our to
do through the user
you
now from here let's head over back to
bootstrap and we're gonna get our form
so we're just going to head over to the
search bar I'm going to type form group
and I'm just gonna click that and this
is going to take us here and this looks
pretty good so we have our label and we
have an input where the user can type
his - duze to submit so I'm just going
to copy this let's head back over to
Visual Studio code and we're just going
to paste this within here
tidy this up a bit
now we only need one of these so I'm
just going to delete the second one now
let's just scroll over to the right a
bit and we're going to change some of
this stuff so we're going to change the
example label too to do
and we're going to give an ID attribute
to our input field so we're just going
to change this from form group example
input to
to do user input and we're going to
change the placeholder to say to do
next we actually have to create a button
so that the user can actually submit
and we're going to give it a class of
primary
and that's actually called a button
create now you could call this button
post because that's the endpoint that
we're gonna be hitting when we click
this button but I'm just gonna call it
create and that's gonna create our to do
and before I forget let's actually
change what the labels for so it's not
foreign group example input is gonna be
for our to do alright now from here this
actually looks good so let's head over
back to bootstrap and get our unordered
list and we're going to be using to
display our two do's through the user so
from here let's go back to our search
I'm going to type unordered and let's
click the example they give us well this
is an unordered list and you can see
that has a bunch of list items here I'm
just gonna copy this let's head back
over to visual studio code from here
let's just move over here and we're
going to paste it in the second row
so I'm just gonna tidy this up a bit
let's give an ID attribute to our list
group I'm just gonna say ID and I'm just
gonna call it display because this is
just gonna be displaying our two dues to
the user and for right now I'm going to
leave these list items here but we are
going to be dynamically adding these
list items to our unordered list all
right so that's it for our HTML part
let's actually start coding some
JavaScript so I'm just going to come
down here and we're going to add a
script tag here
two men thought ready
so now let's actually get our HTML
elements that we attached ID attributes
to so I'm just going to say comps
display and this is going to be the
display for our two dues
I'm going to say Const form and this is
going to be the ID of our form
and I'm going to say cons to do user
input and this is going to be the to do
that the user types in
so first off I think I forgot to add
to the forum so let me do that now
our form we're going to give it an ID
attribute and we're going to call it
form and we're giving this ID attribute
to the form because we want to prevent
default so when the user actually submit
we're going to prevent the default
action that takes place because we want
to make a restful call to our server API
now let's go back down here
so next we're going to code several
helper functions so I'm just going to
say kotts reset to dues input and this
is going to reset the to do user input
field
create a function called build IDs and
this is going to build unique IDs to
give through our HTML elements
and it's going to take in a to-do
document
and we're just going to return an object
with our ID so I'm just gonna say edit
ID and edit ID is going to be attached
to our edit button so we can attach a
click event to that edit button
and you can see that we're taking
advantage of the primary key that we get
from our to do document to make it
unique next we're going to code delete
ID
and delete ID is going to be attached
through our delete buttons so we could
attach a click event to our delete
button
next we're going to create a list item
ID and this is going to be the ID of the
Li element within our unordered list
and the last ID that we're going to
create is going to be called to do ID
and this is going to be the ID of our to
do
now let's code a
for function and this function is
actually going to build the template the
list item that we want to append to our
unordered list I'm just gonna say cons
build template and it's gonna take in
two parameters I'm gonna pass an R to do
and the IDs
a string
that will be appended so from here let's
actually scroll up and let's get our Li
element so I'm just going to copy one of
these and realistically we could just
delete this well now let's go back down
let's paste this one within here let's
delete this now let's give this li
element an ID so we're just going to say
ID
going to be equal to IDs dot list item
ID
next let's give it a row
you
and we're going to make each columns of
size four
you
so the first column is where we're
actually going to be storing our to do
so I'm just going to give it an
attribute of ID
we're just gonna say IDs thought to do
ID and we don't want to actually display
our to do to the user I'm just gonna say
to do dot to do next let's go back to
the last column so I'm just gonna give
this an additional class and I'm just
going to cause a text to the right so we
want our buttons to be to the right of
this
and we're going to have two buttons
within here so I'm just gonna say but in
type II go it's the button
going to give it a class of secondary
and we're going to give it an attribute
of the ID that we create it
and the button is just gonna say now
that we have our
edit button let's copy this and now it's
time to make our delete button so we're
going to change this from secondary to
the danger class and we're going to
change IDs to delete ID and the name of
our button is going to be called delete
let me just take a look at this to make
sure I typed out everything all right
and this looks good and the last helper
function that we're going to be coding
is called display to do and that's
actually going to display or to do this
to the user I'm just gonna say cons
display to do this and we're gonna pass
in data and this data is going to be an
array of two dues so I'm just gonna say
data dot for each
to do out of each of these
get the IDS of each to do so I'm just
going to say let IDs equal build IDs I'm
going to pass in our to do
next let's actually append each of these
list items through our unordered list so
I'm just gonna say display append and
we're going to call the build template
method that we just created and we're
going to pass in our to-do and our IDs
afterwards we're going to call our edit
to do function now we haven't created
this function yet and we'll do so in the
next tutorials but basically the edit to
do function and our delete to do
function is going to add a click event
to our edit button and our delete button
I'm just going to say to do and we're
going to pass in IDs that we do ID and
IDs thought edit ID and likewise we're
just gonna say delete to do and we're
going to pass an R to do all right these
dot list item ID and ID's thought delete
ID
so let's add ace
we come in here and this is pretty much
where I want to leave you guys at so we
created our HTML file and we've added
all our helper functions that's gonna
help display our data to the user
welcome to part 7 of building our crud
application from scratch so in this
tutorial what we're gonna do is display
our two dues to the user by making an
HTTP GET request using the fetch API so
if you remember from our previous
tutorials we coded this get route does
it get to dues and the job of our get to
do is route is to actually get all our
to dues from the database and return it
and it's going to be returned within an
array well now if I head over to our
index.html what we're going to do is
have the fetch API call this get to do
is route I'm just going to go here and
I'm going to create a function called
get to do so I'm just gonna say cons yet
to do
and within here we could use the fetch
API so I'm just gonna say fetch and it's
going to be the URL or the endpoint that
we want to hit so I'm just gonna say get
to do the next argument is going to be
the type of method that we want to use
so we coded a get method
next we could call it a den method
and we're gonna get a response back from
the server and I'm just gonna say return
response JSON and this is gonna parse
the JSON for us but this is going to
return a promise and when you return a
promise we could chain that promise I'm
just gonna call it done method once
again that's in our data and now here
I'm just gonna console dot log to data
and we're gonna pass this data this
array of two dues to our helper method
so I'm just gonna call it display two
dues and we're gonna pass in our data
now let's just add this semicolon here
and let's actually invoke or get to do
is method and now if I was to save this
and let's open up a terminal and I'm
just gonna clear it I'm gonna say node
app let's start up the server so now
let's open up our browser so now from
here let's just type localhost port 3000
and you can see that our two duties are
being loaded so let's bring up the
developer tools so I'm just gonna hit
f12 and we go to our console you can see
the array that the server is sending us
so if we open that up you can see our
two Do's we have our primary key and to
do now let's head over back to visual
studio code to see how this is working
so now if we come back here we can see
that our array of two dues is being
passed into our display to do this let's
take a look at what display to do is is
doing so display to do is actually
taking an array of two dues it's
building its unique IDs or are HTML
elements and it's calling build template
now build template is going to be used
to build our list element that we're
going to add to the unordered list so
you can see that happening here once we
build this HTML template we're returning
it and it is going to be appended to our
unordered list but that's pretty much
how we are displaying our - dues to the
user looking apart eighth of building
our crud application from scratch
on this tutorial we're gonna be making
an HTTP POST request using the fetch API
so if you remember from our previous
tutorial we coded this post route and we
just gave it forward slash it's gonna
take data from the users we're gonna
have to post data back via the body and
you can see that it returns two things
the result whether or not we
successfully deleted the item or not and
it returns back the inserted document
that we just inserted well let's head
over to index that HTML and let's
actually go with this so from here we're
gonna use our form that we have up here
so this is our form and what we want to
do is prevent the default form
submission so we're gonna come down here
and I'm just gonna say form dot submit
and this is gonna take in a function and
it's gonna have an event and what we're
going to do is say e dot prevent default
from occurring next we're gonna call it
a fetch API so I'm just gonna say fetch
we're going to use our endpoint of
forward slash the next argument is going
to be our options so the first option is
we're posting data back to the server
I'm just gonna say posts our second
property is going to be the body what
we're sending back to the database so
i'm just gonna say json dot stringify
and we're going to send back our to do
so we're just going to use to do use our
input and we're going to get the value
that our input field has at the moment
let me just move this over here
and the last option is we're gonna have
to pass in headers and what a header is
is it tells the server what kind of
content you're sending back to it so I'm
just gonna say content type and we're
sending back JSON
now from here let's call it the den
method so I'm just gonna say den we're
gonna get our response back from the
server we're gonna return that response
that JSON which is going to be a promise
that parses the data for us we're just
going to call it then on the promise
that's being returned and we're going to
get our data back next we're going to
have to test to see whether or not we
successfully inserted the document I'm
just going to say if the data result
okay is equal to 1 and data dot result n
is equal to 1 that means our to do was
successfully insert it into our database
I'm just going to say let IDs equal to
build IDs and we're going to pass in our
document
next we're going to call it the display
method so this is going to append a new
list through our unordered list
and last but not least we're going to
have to attach our click events through
our edit button so I'm just going to
call edit to do which is a function we
haven't created yet and we're going to
pass in our to do our to do ID and the
ID of our button
we're going to have the attach event to
our delete button as well
SNR to do
the list item ID and the reason we're
passing in the list item ID is because
we need the ID of the list that we want
to delete and we're gonna pass in the ID
of the delete button so for now I'm just
gonna comment these two out because they
don't exist at the moment right now we
have displayed pen and this looks good
to me and last but not least once this
successfully happens what we want to do
is actually reset our to do is input
so let's actually test this out so I'm
just gonna hit ctrl shift and backtick
let's clear the terminal node app let's
open up a browser so now let's actually
test this out so I'm just gonna come up
here and testing post I'm going to click
the create button and you can see that
our to-do was successfully posted
through the database so I'm just going
to hit refresh to see if it actually
worked and you can see that our data is
persisting so that's the basics of using
the fetch API to post to the server and
welcome to part 9 of building our crud
application from scratch so on this
tutorial we're going to be making a HTTP
delete request using the fetch API so in
the previous tutorials you can see that
we coded our App table delete route and
it's using a route parameter we get that
ID of the to do that we want to delete
here and then here we call the find one
and delete function we pass in our
primary key Ord ID and what we end up
getting is the result whether or not we
successfully deleted the to-do document
within our collection now let's actually
head over to index.html and let's
actually code our delete to do function
well now from here I'm just gonna say
cons delete to do
and it's going to take in three
parameters it's going to take a to do is
going to take the list item ID and it's
going to take the delete ID now to do is
the document that we want to delete list
item ID is the ID of the list element
within our unordered list that we want
to delete and the delete ID is the ID
that we've given to our delete button
now let's actually code this out first
we need to get our delete button so I'm
just going to say let delete button is
equal to this
next let's actually add a click event to
our delete button so I'm just gonna come
down here leet button dot click and
we're gonna pass in our click Handler
and within here let's actually call our
delete route using the fetch API so I'm
just gonna say fetch and we're going to
pass in our route
next let's actually pass
options so we're actually making a
delete request so I'm just gonna say
method and we're gonna pass in delete
now from here let's call it a den method
to actually execute this fetch function
I'm gonna say then what we're going to
end up getting back is the response from
the server next we're going to return
that response and we're going to call
the JSON method on it and this is going
to return to us a promise so now we
could promise chain I'm just going to
call it then again and we should get
back our data that is fully parsed
now from here let's actually test to see
whether or not we successfully deleted
the to do I'm just gonna say if data
okay is equal to one that means we
successfully deleted our to do so now we
need to remove the Li element from our
unordered list so how do we do that well
we have our list ID
and we're just gonna call the method
remove so this is going to remove our li
element from our unordered list well
that's actually add a semicolon here all
right now from here let's go down to our
display to do this and alright so we
already have the AR delete to do
uncomment it so if this should work well
now I'm just gonna save this let's go
back to app dot J yes let's actually
open up our terminal and from here let's
actually run our application note app
and you can see that our application is
up and running and now let's head over
to our web browser and let's actually
test this out so from here you can see
our to-do application is up and running
I'm just gonna refresh this just a
triple-check and what we want to do is
actually hit our delete button to see
other work so I'm just gonna hit the
leap and you see that testing post is
gone if I hit delete again you can see
cleanroom is gone and if I hit refresh
you can see that this does persist onto
the database and that those two do's are
actually deleted from our database and
welcome to part 10 of building our crud
application from scratch so in this
tutorial we're going to be making a HTTP
put request using the fetch API so in
the previous tutorial we coded our app
that put route so this is the endpoint
that we're going to hit we're using
route params and this is going to be the
ID of the document that we want to edit
we're also sending data back via the
body as you can see here and this is
going to be the data that we want to
update with right here you can see that
we are finding by the ID so this gets
the document that we want update
this is updating the document here and
if you scroll here you can see that
we're sending back the result whether or
not we were successfully able to update
the document or not so now let's
actually head over to our index.html
file and actually code this I'm just
gonna come down here and I'm gonna call
it the function edit to do
and it's going to take in three
parameters first is going to be the to
do second is going to be the to do ID
and third is going to be the edit ID the
first parameter to do is obviously the
document that we want to edit to do ID
is the ID of the to do and edit ID is
the ID of the button now let's just come
down here and now from here what I want
to do is actually get our button
and once we get our button what we want
to do is attach a click event to it so
I'm just gonna say edit button
but click SN R callback and from here we
can use the fetch API to hit our
endpoint in our server I'm just going to
say fetch and the endpoint is forward
slash and the ID of the - dude that we
want to edit
the second argument is going to be our
options so we're just going to say
method and we're going to set that to a
put request
we're gonna set our headers and our
headers are going to be set and they're
going to tell our server that we're
sending back JSON
all right now from here let's set up one
more property and it's gonna be our body
so what we're gonna do is actually send
what we want to update our document with
i'm just gonna say json stringify and
this is going to convert our JavaScript
object into JSON for us and I'm just
gonna say to do
and we're going to get the users input
well now that we have our options set up
let's call it a den method to execute
this fetch request here we're going to
get our response from the server now
we're going to return that response and
we're going to call a function called
JSON
now this response that JSON is going to
return a promise so I'm just going to go
down here and I'm going to call it then
and it's going to give us our parsed
data back so now I'm just going to test
to see whether or not we successfully
updated our to do I'm just gonna say if
data dot okay is equal to one that means
that everything went okay now what I
need to do is actually get R to do
element so I'm just gonna say let to do
index equal
equal our to do ID next what I want to
do is actually set our data so I'm just
gonna say to do index.html is going to
be set to the data that we just got back
from the server
now what I want to do is reset the users
input so I'm just going to call the
reset to do input function
I'm just gonna scroll down just to check
to see if we have our edit to do is
being called
and it's being called here alright so
let's actually test this out in our web
browser to see if it actually works
I'm just going to save this I'm going to
open up the terminal I'm gonna clear it
node app
head over to our browser Oh from here
you can see that we have our application
running just gonna hit refresh just to
make sure and right here I'm just going
to type whatever and now I'm going to
hit edit and you can see that our to-do
document was updated so just gonna hit
refresh again let's see if it persists
to the database and you can see that it
is persisting and let's try one more
just to make sure and you can see that
it is indeed working welcome to part 11
of building our crud application from
scratch so in this tutorial we're going
to be doing some user input validation
using joy so to get started let's
actually install joy I'm just going to
come down here NPM install Juhi
now that we have our joy package
installed let's just lien cluded it
within our application so I'm just gonna
come up here I'm gonna say Kant's joy is
equal to require joy now from here let's
actually develop a schema for a to-do
document now if you don't know what a
schema is it's basically a blueprint
that an object has to follow
so let's come down here and let's define
our schema I'm just gonna say Kant's
schema is equal to joy not object and
now we want to define our keys
now from here we're gonna give our
properties and the type that they should
be so for example we only have really
one object within this tutorial and
that's what to do so here I have a to do
and the type that this should be is of
type string so I'm just gonna say joy
doc string and we're going to make it
required
so when the user input is to do this
schema is gonna make sure that it's a
string and that it's not empty
so required means that if the user tries
to submit a to-do that's empty we're
gonna get an error if the user tries to
submit a number instead of a string
we're gonna get an error but that's how
we're gonna validate user input so I'm
just gonna end a semicolon here now
let's take a look at our routes so what
we want to do is validate anything we
get back from the user so for example
this route parameter here we would want
to validate now this is not a to do
object but this is the primary key but
anything the user sends back to us you
would want the validate so this request
body we would also want to validate for
and if we take a look here request body
here request params here and that's
pretty much it so for this tutorial I'm
gonna do one example with you guys and
you guys could pretty much figure out
how to do the rest yourselves so I'm
gonna choose to do our poster out but
we're going to validate the user input
sent by the body
here I'm gonna call joy dot validate and
validate is a method which is going to
take three arguments the first argument
is the object that you want to validate
so we're passing in user input the
second argument is the schema or the
blueprint that you want to check against
user input but we're just going to pass
in our schema we just created and the
third argument is our callback function
and we get the error and we get the
result now from here I'm going to say if
there's an error what I want to do is
we're going to create an error so I'm
just gonna say Const error is equal to
new error and we're gonna pass in the
message that we want to display to the
user I'm just gonna say invalid input
next I'm gonna give this error a HTTP
status code so I'm just gonna say error
dot status and I'm just gonna set that
to 400 next what I want to do is call
the next method and that's because we're
gonna have a middleware handle our
errors I'm just gonna say next and we're
going to pass in the error we just
created so from here since we're using a
a middleware we have to pass in next as
a parameter so now from here let's code
our else statement so if there's no
errors with the users input what do we
want to do so I'm just gonna say else
and what we want to do is actually get
our database I'm just gonna cut this out
I'm gonna paste this in with in here and
now here what we can do is some more
error handling so right here I could
come here instead of just printing this
out to the console what I could do is
exactly what I did a book I could copy
this just paste this in here
and instead of saying invalid input I
could say
something like this I could say failed
to insert to do document and we're gonna
leave the status coat the same and we're
gonna call our middleware
error handle here so from here we could
go down to this else statement and we're
gonna have to pass in a couple more
things and this is just to make it
easier for the front end so for example
we are gonna pass in a message and this
message is going to be displayed if we
successfully insert it into the database
so i'm just gonna say successfully
insert it to do
the next thing that we're going to pass
in is an error property and we're going
to set that to null so that means that
there was no errors and we're gonna be
using this to test and our front end so
this looks good to me
well now let's code our custom error
handler our custom middleware
I'm just gonna go down here and
[Music]
let's put it here well now I'm just
going to say app thought use and we're
going to pass in our error object next
is going to be the request object the
response object and the next object now
here what I could do is actually send a
response back from the server well now
I'm just going to say res dot status and
we're going to set the status to the
error status that we set in our post
route I'm just gonna say error dot
status next I'm going to call it the
JSON method so we're going to be sending
this back to the user and from here I'm
going to pass in an error property and
this is going to be an object and it's
going to have property a message and
we're going to pass in our error message
I'm just going to say error message
all right now from here what I want to
do is
let's head over to bootstrap and let's
get our alert that we're gonna be using
to display to the user so let's go to
bootstrap and get our alert that we're
going to be using to display to the user
whether or not our post request was
successful or not so from here I'm just
gonna go to search I'm going to type
alert and you can see that we have a
bunch of alerts here what I want to do
is get our success alert and we're gonna
be using this to display when we
successfully posted something and I want
to use the danger alert when we get an
error I'm just gonna come down here and
we only need one of these so I'm just
gonna pick up the danger one I'm gonna
copy this and I'm just gonna head back
to visual studio code now from here I'm
just gonna save our app dot J's file and
I'll go to index.html and what I want to
do is actually put this underneath our
display though right here I'm just gonna
paste this here and let's actually steal
some code from our display I'm just
going to add a break here just to give
us some space I'm going to copy this I'm
going to paste this here
[Applause]
want to do is get rid of this unordered
list and we're gonna be putting our
alerts here so I'm just going to copy
this
taste this in here let's tidy this up a
bit and what I want to do is actually
get rid of this and let's add an ID
attribute of message
from here let's actually scroll down to
our script tag and what we want to do is
actually get our message that we just
gave an ID for I'm just gonna say con
some message and we're gonna be getting
our ID
now from here I'm just gonna say message
God hide because I don't want to show it
yet next thing I want to do is create a
helper function so I'm just gonna come
down here just gonna say can't display
message and the first parameter is gonna
be a flag whether or not we should
display the success alert or the danger
alert the second argument is going to be
the message that we want to display now
from here I'm just gonna say if flag so
if this is true and let's actually make
a comment so if we had a successful post
what we want to do is I'm going to say
message dot remove class and we're going
to remove the alert - danger class and
I'm just gonna copy this paste this and
we're going to change this to add class
and we're gonna add a success alert next
I'm going to say message dot HTML and
we're going to pass in the message that
we want to display and I'm gonna say
message dot show actually display our
alert so now from here since we have a
success we need a else statement to
display to failure so I'm just gonna say
else and now I'm just going to copy all
of this and pretty much we're gonna do
two opposite so instead of saying remove
danger class we're going to remove the
success class and here we're going to be
adding the danger class and these two
lines of code are gonna be the same so
actually by coding this I actually
forgot to remove this part from our HTML
so yeah so let's get rid of this
and we have our alert and we have our
message okay so that looks good so now
let's actually go down to our post
host and from here what we're going to
do is actually wrap this if statement so
I'm just going to come up here I'm going
to say if and we're going to use the not
symbol so data dot error so there are no
errors what we want to do is execute
this block of code
we want to do is actually get our alert
to display I'm just gonna say display
message and we're gonna set this to true
because that means that everything went
okay and then we're gonna pass in the
message that we want to display I'm just
gonna say dated on message and from here
I'm gonna make an L statement
I'm just gonna copy this paste this here
instead of true we're gonna say false
and let's display our error message so
I'm just gonna say data dot error
message now from here let's actually go
back down we do have to reset our to do
input so I'm just going to call it that
so now let me just save this and let's
actually test this out so I'm just going
to come down here node app and let's see
what we got wrong oh joy dot string dot
require this require is not a function
let's go back to our app dot J s
probably not required it's probably
required well now let's save this let's
clear the terminal node app all right so
now our application is up and running
and now let's actually test this in the
browser now we have our to-do
application up and running so now if I
was type of string and hit create you
see that we guess successfully inserted
to do and if I was to have an empty
string and hit create you can see that
nothing's updating so that means that we
made it error so now let's head back to
visual studio code so from here let's
just go back to our index that HTML file
let's actually take a look at this so we
have our if statement here and that's
pretty much the reason because this if
block is only supposed to be wrapped
around this if condition but we also
have our else block here
well this code isn't being executed so
let's actually copy this let's get that
out of there
and from here you just paste that here
two resets here now let's say this for
now let's head back to the browser I'm
just going to hit refresh to reload the
page and we could test this one more
time
so we inserted our to do okay now we
have a blank user input it create and
you can see that we get a warning
invalid input that's pretty much how you
can validate user input using joy or our
to do application